[Music]
yesterday
[Music]
good morning today we're going to my
first friending festival ever apparently
i'm just waiting for my mum to come in
to drive me to the train station so i'll
be volunteering there as part of the
festival medical services so i get to
see arctic monkeys madison bear halsey
and so many more artists for free and my
meals are going to be paid for as well
i've got two night shifts and one of
them is tonight i'll be dealing with
lots of drug overdoses and other types
of injuries that are involved in
festival setting the patients i'll be
treating will be a lot younger this time
more like 16 to 18 year olds because to
reading festival usually post gcse or
post a level students come in the uk but
i'll see you guys there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
these are one of the vehicles we drive
to reach patients who can't come to the
medical tent themselves for example a
patient who can't walk due to an injury
in their legs or due to intoxication
when they can't even stand up if there
is no need for driving then we walk to
the patient's location wearing these
bags which contains any first aid kit
that we'd need to be able to help them
all the patients were seen so we now
finish the job and we are
wandering around
[Music]
that was actually amazing
[Music]
[Music]
then we watched dave while we were on
chef and had pizza that one of the food
stores kindly gave us for free just
because we were from the medical center
[Music]
i don't want drama in there
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
i wanna start up something new
i wanna see things
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
or any
[Music]
the same things that you can't say
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
that should be the microphone
[Music]
our current location is here this is the
med center directly ahead of one it's
the yellow campsite the recap of my last
and second night shift i came straight
from work take monkeys to my chef and
learned how to use the festival map then
i started to reaching patients and
taking histories from them and actually
one of the patients that i helped that
night recognize me the next day and
thanked me and told me that i almost
saved his life yesterday which made me
feel quite emotional and i felt like i
actually made some kind of a good
difference and this is my first time
ever hearing something like this from a
patient and i feel like i didn't do much
for him but these kind of moments make
it all worthwhile and this is something
that you never forget and sticks with
you for life but anyway then during my
break i had some toast and did my
skincare whilst trying not to fall
asleep since i've done it all during my
break this way i could go straight to
sleep after my shift ended
james was on his way to his day shift
he caught me on my way back and of
course laughed at my pain
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you